- Can I have more of the tequila ones?
(laughing)
That's my final thought.
- Yeah, are we allowed to eat more?
- We are here to taste
test some different gummies
and the alcohol that it
may or may not taste like.
- I like gummy candy,
because it is delicious,
and it's the best kind of candy.
- Candy with alcohol, I think,
is just genius.
- Everyone needs a little bit
of drinking during the day
to get them through it,
and might as well try it with the gummies.
- I'm hoping that these are more sugary
than alcoholic, that they
have a whisper of alcohol.
- Are you ready to try the candies?
- I'm ready.
- Okay, let's do it.
(jazz music)
- That is very sugary.
- I can take the bourbon.
- Mm-hmm.
- But --
- That's not bad.
- How many do you need
to have a shot of this?
- Cheers.
- Yup, cheers.
- Mm-mm.
I'm done, nope.
- Ooh, man.
- Gummy bears.
- I'm gonna chase it with a gummy bear.
- Uh-huh.
- Is that okay?
- These gummy bears are more of a treat
for me to have during the day at work.
This will make me die.
- Yeah, the gummy bear's
better than the alcohol there.
- Agree.
- Yeah, the gummy doesn't make you feel
like the warm bourbon feeling.
- Yeah.
- You normally get.
(salsa music)
- Oh my God.
I'm so about it.
- Can't taste the tequila.
- Mm-mm.
It doesn't taste anything like tequila.
If tequila tasted like this,
I would drink it all the time.
- I may have to steal them for later.
- I can eat like, I'm not kidding,
like a ton of these.
- Can I throw one in your mouth?
(salsa music)
(laughing)
- I was curious if that
was like, salt, but.
- What if we eat a gummy,
and then take the shot?
- Yeah, let it absorb.
- Cheers.
- Mm-mm-hmm.
Cheers.
- Yes.
- Mm-mm-mm-mm.
- Tequila with a gummy chaser, yup.
- It's closer than the bourbon was.
- If they turned this
flavor into a margarita,
I would drink that real fast.
But the shot itself?
You took the whole thing?
- Yeah, I told you, I love tequila.
(soft, mellow music)
- I think this is a good,
guess all right snack.
- These are delicious.
- I feel like these have the perfect blend
of they taste like a gummy bear
the way a gummy bear's
supposed to taste like,
and they also taste like champagne.
- Oh, no, those are really
like tart in flavor.
- I'd almost be scared to have them,
because I feel like I'd have 20 of them,
and I might end up wasted,
if there is alcohol content.
- That did its job.
That is alcoholic candy.
- Cheers.
- I like the champagne more.
- This is so good.
I'll finish this.
- We have to work.
- We do have to work.
I feel flushed.
Am I like going red?
Am I sweaty?
- I know, right?
I haven't had lunch yet.
Am I little tipsy?
I might be a little tipsy.
Is that sad?
(whimsical music)